come on
welcome to this game playing amazing
grace from Germany maybe a group thought
I rarely play that simply because I have
no great knowledge about it
oops let's go for my t6 this is an
interesting line and 94 what's the point
Ruki a door c6
I think c6 is right this has been
recently a plate rook e8 now or take
locate oh no maybe you can even take one
c6
hmm I want to play that now interesting
even b5 is an idea I just spotted that
one
well probably not a great idea I thought
Bishop d7 before but it's not terrible
okay and we can really take c6 okay
so um yeah active pieces but really
doubtful that this is enough for upon no
I know maybe maybe there is some
compensation I can't play Bishop d3 now
okay so if he doesn't threaten to take
this is important because medium made
maybe maybe 97 97 to e5 4 to c5 yeah ok
there's there is some play
not sure if it's enough on how to assess
this correctly but I'm not so completely
without any any chances
some nights if five year
b5 is my idea b5 before maybe he can
play Bishop III now
and the five he can probably just take I
just recognize that might be five Bishop
b5 rook c5 pusher pretty - yeah well
anyway I thought Bishop f8 but this is
not working at all
and can i play Bishop b2 yeah it's not
helping it should be - rook c8 Bishop e3
rookie a rookie ed and unjust and still
a pawn down for four not much okay let's
try that one
just e6 okay now can I can take you one
okay not this six but it looks really
awful
the only minimal hope is services we
pick Ryan Quincy - very Quincy - but
it's got Queen b3 still I feel that this
one wasn't so so great
can i play Bishop deform maybe or Quincy
- Quincy - I just got this Queen b3 move
so I don't know this feels
time warning okey one
yeah I can't download three seconds and
he's got d7 as well black forfeits on
time so all this was stupid I spent ages
for this yeah maybe this is just
nonsense the comp just gives white a big
advantage around here I don't believe
that don't know maybe the deep hole is
too strong it's possible but around here
was just losing the threat and it's just
just not a good position I mean probably
here there is something else to to play
this is probably a bad move I know that
this is compensation I mean very strong
GM's have played this but I'm not sure
what what is the right move on Quincy
form maybe rookie aide this is maybe
questionable I really didn't have have
enough here maybe just b5 I don't know
yeah well thanks for watching